Transcription: Giada Sanna
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir, très heureux d’être là,
merci d’être là et merci au TEDx
qui va me permettre de vous parler de
40 ans de recherches en biodiversité.
Je ne vais pas tous vous les raconter.
Je vais juste vous dire un truc que
je n’avais pas compris pendant 38 ans
et que j’ai compris
il n’y a pas longtemps.
C’est vexant pour un chercheur,
je l’avoue.
Bien sûr, la biodiversité se porte mal.
Il y a eu des appels il y a
un peu plus de trois ans.
On avait été 15 000 scientifiques
au niveau mondial
à signer un texte qui a été repris
dans les journaux français.
Ce texte, c’était le second
avertissement à l’humanité
pour se préoccuper
des problèmes de la planète.
Le premier avertissement est
nettement plus vieux, il date de 1992.
En 1992, un groupe de scientifiques
dont je faisais partie
a écrit un premier avertissement.
92, c’était l’année du sommet de Rio.
Les plus âgés ici peuvent s’en souvenir.
Et effectivement, c’était le moment où
on a commencé à parler de biodiversité.
Cet appel a été écrit au moment du sommet
de Rio et est resté totalement invisible.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’au même moment,
un autre appel a été écrit,
l’appel de Heidelberg.
L’appel de Heidelberg
a été lancé en Europe.
Il y a eu 4 000 signataires,
dont beaucoup de prix Nobel.
Cet appel, en fait, envoyait
le message inverse.
Il disait : « Attention,
les défenseurs de l’environnement
sont souvent animés
par une idéologie perverse,
qui s’oppose au développement
scientifique et industriel. »
Et ça, c’est un problème
qu’on a maintenant depuis longtemps :
souvent, au nom de la rationalité,
on condamne l’écologie.
Comment une chose pareille peut arriver ?
Je peux déjà vous dire
comment ça a commencé.
Qui a écrit cet appel de Heidelberg ?
On le sait maintenant : l’industrie de
l’amiante aidée de celle du tabac.
Eh oui ! Ce sont eux
qui ont écrit cet appel
signé par plein de scientifiques qui ne
savaient pas du tout ce qu’ils signaient.
Et tout ça fait partie
d’un vaste mouvement
que des sociologues américains
ont appelé les marchands de doute.
Ce livre très important, publié il y a
assez peu de temps, explique ça.
Ces marchands de doute vont agir
sur tout ce qui est écologique,
à finir par la biodiversité.
Je vais vous expliquer comment ça marche.
La biodiversité, elle se porte mal.
J’ai mis deux photos pour vous avertir,
mais je pense que vous le savez tous.
Première chose : il faut comprendre
ce qu’est la biodiversité.
Il faut s’enlever l’image du paradis
terrestre avec Adam et Ève au milieu.
Ce n’est pas comme ça que ça marche.
On sait depuis plus de 150 ans maintenant,
avec les travaux de Darwin,
que c’est quelque chose de beaucoup
plus dynamique qu’une simple création.
Ce n’est pas facile
de se le mettre dans le crâne.
Il n’y a pas un état ancestral qui allait
bien, il y a une dynamique constante.
Darwin décrit dans son livre
l’histoire de la vie
avec un schéma qui n’est pas très sexy,
mais qui est extrêmement parlant.
Si on regarde bien,
vous avez donc le temps qui va de bas
en haut et qui est divisé en couches -
Darwin était géologue au départ.
On ne va pas tout regarder,
ça serait trop long.
Regardez ce qui part de la lettre A :
c’est une forme vivante.
Elle fabrique des tas de nouveautés,
tout le temps.
La plupart de ces nouveautés s’éteignent.
Celles sur les bords s’éteignent
moins que les autres
car souffrant moins de la compétition.
Du coup, les limites divergent.
Il y a donc un processus de divergence
associé avec des processus d’extinction.
La biodiversité,
c’est cette dynamique constante,
des divergences d’un côté,
des extinctions de l’autre.
Et ça crée un équilibre dynamique.
Ce n’est pas un équilibre statique,
ça ne se maintient pas sans bouger.
Au contraire, c’est parce que ça bouge
que ça tient, comme un vélo :
parce qu’il avance, il tient.
Si jamais il s’arrête,
il se casse la figure.
Il ne faut pas oublier ça : on n’arrêtera
pas le mouvement de la biodiversité.
Si on essaye, on la fera tomber.
À l’heure actuelle, on constate que
la biodiversité se porte extrêmement mal :
l’équilibre est en train de se casser
la figure dans son mouvement.
On a plein d’éléments -
je ne vais pas en donner beaucoup.
Je vais en donner un que je trouve
très important, sur lequel on va revenir :
près de 80 % de la biomasse
d’insectes a disparu
dans les zones protégées
européennes en 30 ans.
Dans les réserves, on a perdu 80 % de la
biomasse d’insectes en seulement 30 ans.
Si on recommence pendant encore 30 ans,
qu’on reperd 80% des 20% qui restent, il
commencera à ne plus rester grand-chose,
et on pourra s’inquiéter.
Il y a donc une relative urgence.
Tout ça est bien expliqué
par des organismes généraux.
Vous connaissez le GIEC ?
Il y a la même chose
pour la biodiversité : l’IPBES.
C’est tenu par l’ONU.
L’IPBES fait des rapports pour dire que
tout va mal, dans l’indifférence générale.
Ils vous donnent les extinctions,
les chutes d’effectifs, etc.
Mais les marchands de doute sont
toujours à l’œuvre. D’où viennent-ils ?
On peut dater à peu près
le début de ça à décembre 1953.
En décembre 1953, ça a été étudié
par un spécialiste des relations publiques
qui s’appelait Cutlip.
Que s’est-il passé ?
Dans un grand hôtel de New York,
un spécialiste des relations publiques,
John Hill,
rencontre les grands marchands
de tabac américains
et leur explique qu’ils vont avoir
un problème avec le cancer du fumeur -
le cancer du poumon plus exactement -
on était en 1953 -
et que s’ils se contentent de [nier],
ça ne marchera pas.
Ce qu’il faut faire, c’est créer
une controverse scientifique majeure.
Les relations publiques vont se
transformer en ingénieurs sociaux
qui vont effectivement manipuler
la science et l’opinion
pour qu’on ne voit pas ce que
les entreprises ne veulent pas qu’on voie.
Effectivement, ça va marcher : de 1953 -
on savait déjà ce qui se passait -
jusqu’à l’an 2000,
c’est-à-dire jusqu’à la fin du siècle.
Cinquante ans d'obscurantisme
sur les questions du tabac.
Tout ça a été remarquablement décrit
par un historien américain,
Robert Proctor,
qui a écrit « Golden Holocaust ».
C’est la traduction française
que je vous montre là.
L’ingénierie sociale
va fonctionner comment ?
Elle va favoriser des chercheurs,
des recherches,
infiltrer des entreprises,
de manière à faire croire que le cancer
du poumon a des causes multifactorielles.
Ça, c’est vrai.
Il dépend de facteurs génétiques,
de l’environnement, du stress, etc.
Il y avait un facteur qui était énorme
par rapport aux autres, c’était le tabac,
mais il est parmi d’autres.
Le jeu consiste à faire voir tout le reste
et à cacher le tabac derrière,
de créer un écran de fumée -
c’est le cas de le dire.
On va expliquer que c’est multifactoriel
et qu’il faut plus de recherche.
Quand c’est fait, vous avez gagné :
personne ne prendra de mesures
pour arrêter ce que vous faites.
Que vont faire les marchands de tabac ?
Ils vont infiltrer les organisations.
L’OMS a publié un rapport de 200 pages
en l’an 2000
pour montrer à quel point
ils avaient été infiltrés :
recruter des grands scientifiques,
un prix Nobel, un des plus grands
physiciens américains de l’époque,
le président de l’Académie
des sciences américaine Seitz.
Ces deux-là, d’ailleurs, ont commencé
par militer pour le tabac.
Lui a même dirigé
l’Institut de recherche sur le tabac
payé par les grands cigarettiers.
Ensuite, ils vont se reconvertir,
ils vont devenir climato-sceptiques,
c’est la même chose, on va le voir.
Pourquoi de grands scientifiques font ça ?
Ils reçoivent de l’argent,
mais il y a aussi un côté idéologique.
Ces grands scientifiques sont persuadés
que les écologistes sont des gens qui vont
les empêcher de faire de la technique,
qui vont empêcher le progrès auquel
ils rêvent sur le plan technique,
qui vont donner un poids trop gros à
l’État, alors qu’ils sont super libéraux.
En fait, ils militent contre l’écologie
de ce point de vue-là.
L’écologie, vue comme une force politique
nocive par ces conservateurs américains :
l’écologie est comme les pastèques,
verte dehors et rouge dedans.
De quoi faire peur.
Du coup, la parole scientifique va devenir
une parole extrêmement critiquable.
On va venir affirmer scientifiquement
des tas de choses
qui sont en fait absolument idéologiques
dans ces domaines.
Ça a été décrit dans
un livre écrit par trois Français,
deux journalistes et un sociologue,
que vous trouvez
à la librairie Gwalarn, bien sûr.
Je vous conseille de lire ça
si ces questions vous intéressent.
Le jeu consiste à faire croire
que le cancer du poumon est multifactoriel
qu’il faut plus chercher,
mais ça peut l’appliquer ailleurs.
En particulier, et c’est ça que
je n’ai compris que très récemment,
ça a été appliqué à la biodiversité.
Moi aussi, j’ai dit :
« La biodiversité, c’est multifactoriel.
Il y a plein de choses qui vont faire
que les espèces s'éteignent, etc.
Il faut chercher plus. »
Nous, chercheurs, ça nous plaît
qu’il faille plus de recherches,
Ça nous fait du boulot.
On l’applique aux abeilles :
elles se cassent la figure,
mais c’est multifactoriel,
il faut plus de recherches.
À chaque fois qu’on vous dira que c’est
multifactoriel sur un problème grave,
demandez-vous si quelqu’un a intérêt
à ce que vous croyez ça.
Stéphane Foucart, le journaliste
du Monde, a fait un livre là-dessus
qui s’appelle
« Et le monde devint silencieux ».
Ce livre rappelle un livre écrit dans
les années 60 par Rachel Kherson,
qui s’appelait
« Le printemps silencieux ».
Ce livre de Rachel Carson
alertait sur le fait que
les pesticides allaient rendre
silencieux nos jardins
et qu’on n’entendrait plus d’oiseaux.
On va prendre l’exemple des abeilles,
pas parce que je m’y intéresse,
mais c’est un cas extrêmement intéressant
et elles représentent tout le reste -
on le verra.
Cette abeille, elle a un petit problème :
sur son dos, vous voyez une petite tique.
Ça s’appelle un varroa.
Le varroa, c’est un petit acarien
qui suce l’hémolymphe des abeilles,
qui leur transmet des maladies.
Il y a plein de recherches sur le varroa
à l’heure actuelle. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les entreprises d’agrochimie
subventionnent les recherches.
D’autres sont méchants avec
les abeilles, dont les frelons asiatiques.
Les abeilles se font manger par eux.
Donc on va faire des recherches
sur le frelon asiatique.
Ça a été pareil avec le tabac.
On est en Bretagne.
Vous savez peut-être que le radon,
la radioactivité qui vient du granit,
ça a été très étudié et qu’on a
dit que ça pouvait causer le cancer.
Qui a subventionné
les recherches sur le radon ?
Les cigarettiers.
Qui subventionne la recherche sur le
varroa, les frelons asiatiques, etc. ?
Les marchands de pesticides. Pourquoi ?
Ce qui fait que depuis 30 ans,
les abeilles se portent mal,
et que tous les insectes et le reste
du monde vivant se portent mal,
c’est qu’on a mis en place
un système pour mettre des pesticides
systématiquement dans les champs.
Avant, on n’en mettait qu’au besoin,
maintenant, ils enrobent les graines :
des graines de blé, de maïs, de betterave.
Tout ça empoisonne
l’ensemble du monde vivant.
Quand, dans le semoir,
les graines s’entrechoquent,
de la poussière sort ;
si le vent l’emporte sur une ruche,
tout le monde meurt dans la ruche,
ça ne rate pas.
Les ingénieurs sociaux vont s’ingénier
à faire que nous ne sachions pas
que c’est à cause des pesticides.
Comment font-ils ?
Comme je l’ai dit,
ils subventionnent des recherches
qui vont dans le sens qui les intéressent,
c’est-à-dire pour toutes les causes,
sauf les pesticides.
Un exemple intéressant a été détecté par
le Guardian il n’y a pas longtemps :
une université anglaise avait décidé
de lancer un programme de recherche
sur la disparition des abeilles.
Toutes les causes - le varroa,
le virus machin chouette,
le parasite Nosema,
les frelons asiatiques -
ont été étudiées grâce à des crédits
donnés par ce programme de recherche.
Toutes sauf les pesticides.
Quand le Guardian s’est demandé pourquoi,
ils ont vu que 10% de l’argent
avait été donné par Syngenta,
un producteur des pesticides.
Ils sont devenus super doués :
même en ne donnant que 10% du budget,
ils orientent les recherches
dans les directions qu’ils veulent.
Un autre exemple intéressant -
j’en aurais des dizaines,
mais ça prendrait trop de temps.
La Société américaine d’entomologie,
ce sont des gens qui aiment les insectes.
Eh bien, ils écrivent
sur leur page de garde que
le problème le plus grave est
qu’on ne sait pas ce qu’il se passe.
Comment ça se fait
qu’ils ne le sachent pas ?
Devinez qui les finance.
Allez à la fin de leur page.
Vous trouverez qu’ils sont financés par
Bayer, Syngenta, Corteva, Johnson et BASF.
Voilà ce qu’il se passe.
On subventionne les trucs qu'il faut
pour pouvoir orienter les choses.
Deuxième méthode : discréditer
les bonnes recherches.
Il y a quelque temps, les apiculteurs
ont dit que leurs abeilles s’effondraient
là où il y avait certains pesticides,
dont particulièrement les néonicotinoïdes.
On leur a dit que des néonicotinoïdes
sur des abeilles ne les tuaient pas.
Des chercheurs se sont mis
à se poser des questions,
ils ont étudié et ont trouvé
qu’elles ne mouraient pas.
Mais elles sont désorientées.
Une abeille qui ne retrouve pas
sa ruche, elle meurt.
Donc, il fallait étudier ça.
Cet article a été publié bien sûr
dans Science, une grande revue,
mais a été immédiatement
critiqué par un autre article
fait par des gens venant des entreprises.
C’est ce deuxième article qui a été le
plus cité dans la presse, pas le premier.
Dernier point : infiltrer
les organisations de régulation.
Il y a quelque temps,
voyant le massacre des abeilles,
l’EFSA, l’agence européenne
qui s’occupe de ces questions,
a décidé de ne pas se contenter
de regarder la toxicité -
est-ce que les pesticides
tuent l’abeille ? -
mais aussi ce qu’il se passe
si elle y est exposée de façon répétée.
Et l’EFSA a proposé un test
qui testerait la toxicité chronique.
Devinez ce qu’il s’est passé.
Ce test n’a jamais été mis en œuvre,
alors que ça fait 10 ans presque
qu’il a été proposé.
Comment ça se fait ?
Il y a un article écrit par les grands
scientifiques des entreprises en question,
signé de Bayer, etc.
Vous pourriez ne pas croire
les écologistes,
mais là, c’est eux qui le disent.
Ils disent que si on met en place le test
de l’EFSA, 79% de leurs herbicides,
75% des fongicides et 92% des insecticides
seront interdits.
De leur aveu même, 80% de leurs produits
tuent les abeilles.
Remarquez bien que ce n’est pas
seulement les insecticides,
c’est même aussi
les herbicides et les fongicides,
faits pour tuer les champignons.
Ça veut dire que les abeilles
sont un signal d’alerte.
Parce que si je regarde
l’histoire de la vie,
vous avez la lignée vers les plantes,
puis la lignée des animaux
et enfin, la lignée vers les champignons.
Un truc fait pour tuer les plantes
qui tue les abeilles, ça tue tout.
Actuellement, le problème
principal de la biodiversité -
Bien sûr, il y a plein de raisons :
on devrait remettre des haies,
arrêter de faire ceci et cela,
faire des champs plus petits,
mais surtout, tant qu’on n’aura pas
arrêté la folie des pesticides
tels qu’on les emploie,
on n’aura aucune chance
de sauver la biodiversité.
Je vous le rappelle, nous sommes
dans un mouvement de biodiversité.
Si jamais on le déséquilibre,
il se casse la figure.
C’est ce qu’on fait.
Nous avons perdu 80% de la biomasse
d’insectes à cause des pesticides.
Nous ne pouvons pas continuer ainsi.
Demain commence aujourd’hui.
Si demain commence aujourd’hui, il faut
dès aujourd’hui arrêter cette folie.
C’est le devoir de tous les citoyens
de demander à ce qu’on arrête
la folie des pesticides
dans nos champs et dans nos campagnes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)